more than a hundred and sixty thousand
Ukrainian refugees have come to the UK
since Russia invaded their country I'm
just trying to move on I'm just trying
simply to survive for many their time
staying with British families is running
out for all of us we don't want to go on
like this forever thousands have already
turned to local councils for somewhere
to live at risk of becoming homeless we
need compassionate landlords a rapidly
increasing number of ukrainians living
in Britain are struggling to find a
place to call home
it's a cold day in early February and
nine months after arriving in the UK
Ukrainian Refugee and feast of lasova is
searching for somewhere to spend the
night whenever I call to Leading agency
and I keep asking empowering property to
you then I face so many difficult
problems as we film a call comes in you
can take it if you want him
hello yeah but there's more
disappointment
okay
yeah thank you thank you it's okay yeah
take care bye
who is that that's one more organization
uh supposed to help with finding shelter
for this night but they're not able
we're in bracknell in Berkshire and
anfisa has to leave the bed and
breakfast where she's been for the last
10 days because it's fully booked from
tonight for months
anyway just keep in touch and if I can
help let me know you know yeah thank you
and there's an added reason why and fisa
is struggling to find a roof over her
head
she needs somewhere pet friendly that
will take her beloved mini Yorkshire
Terriers Betsy Teddy Nora and Daisy
which she brought with her from Ukraine
please they are emotional support dogs
for me they mean everything they mean
word for me because I already lost
everything because of this war
and fisa was originally sponsored to
come to the UK for six months on the
homes for Ukraine scheme when that ended
she was offered another placement with
an elderly man who she says expected her
to be his carer and companion
she stayed in four different places but
is finding it hard to move to the
private rental market
by now it's mid-afternoon and local
councilor Jenny green a fellow dog lover
has arrived to help
today anfisa was offered accommodation
by the council for her and her pets
which she says was unsuitable and turned
it down in one case she says it was a
room with a family who've got a cat
now anfisa is homeless and requires
emergency housing for the night which
comes with conditions
Jenny takes anfisa to the housing
department at the local Council offices
hoping to find an 11th Hour resolution
there is a solution on the table she can
be separated for a short period and go
into bed and breakfast without her dogs
and the dogs can be looked after in
kennels while that goes on but having
brought her pets thousands of miles from
a war zone it isn't an offer and fisa
will contemplate
then as night falls unexpected help
comes from others who are also at the
council looking for accommodation
I'm homeless I'm down in the woods the
other night it was freezing cold I've
gone I'm not proud of this but four or
five days without being able to wash
myself properly
um
we're trying to keep myself presentable
um disabled toilets Etc and where do you
think you'll spend the night tonight uh
be at a church
the group forms an unusual procession as
anfisa who used to work in Ukraine
promoting cosmetics and her new friends
from bracknell's homeless Community make
their way to a nearby Church
and fisa was displaced first from
danetsk in 2014 then she fled from
kharkiv as it was being shelled last
year
now just like those who've brought her
here and fisa is living hand to mouth
she is one of a rapidly Rising number of
Ukrainian refugees turning to local
councils for accommodation
but tonight she'll be sleeping in the
house of God
Jesus always gives shelter
to those who in need
I'm so tired and exhausted because all
day just running calling searching so at
least I got a roof and it's warm and I
got a meal yeah and my dogs with me
available data analyzed by Sky News
shows well over 4 000 Ukrainian refugees
and their families in the UK are needing
somewhere to live after their placements
on the homes for Ukraine scheme ended
the actual number could be even higher
whilst on fisa's situation is unusual
her determination to stay with her pets
leaves her still in need of a long-term
housing solution
in nearby reading at a drop-in event for
refugees and Asylum Seekers there's a
chance to share problems and learn
English
but it becomes clear amongst the
Ukrainian Community their main concern
is housing
the homes for Ukraine scheme asked
British hosts to take refugees for a
minimum of six months like many
ukrainians around the country for these
women their host arrangements are coming
to an end and they're turning to local
councils
at 60 years old armina was a German
teacher in Donetsk now she's on
Universal Credit and hasn't been able to
find work or a rental property
thankfully a second British family have
taken her in but her experience doesn't
give other Ukrainian refugees much hope
yeah very scared when we look for for
the new sources very scared and very we
have been we panic
we panicked and very scared
and now
and now I I I I
am very happy I am very very happy
coordinator Tatiana says without a UK
credit history and often no salary some
refugees are getting rejected by private
landlords who can pick and choose their
tenants half of them at least already in
a month or two months situation before
they need to find next accommodation
which is rather difficult so the main
message is we need compassionate
landlords and we need local authorities
to work with the state agents to
accommodate that so what you're saying
is some landlords don't want ukrainians
some of them I'm not saying all we're
working with some private landlords they
openly help in and they want to help
Ukrainian families some landlords are
completely not really not really
accommodating anything
the seasons have come and gone and the
war in Ukraine has been raging for a
year
until a year ago former history teacher
Katarina konienko led a normal life now
she's on the phone to her husband back
in Odessa working as a teaching
assistant in Berkshire and living with
sponsors with her children on the homes
for Ukraine scheme this is our space
they have their own space own bathroom
living room and bedrooms
but even after such a successful
placement their need to move on explains
why so many ukrainians are turning to
the rental market and local councils for
support it's very good place for us but
it's not our house you know it's not our
property so we I every time remember
that I'm just a guest here and I should
be polite I want to keep their life the
same what it was before
but the difficulties of renting for
Ukrainian refugees means Katarina's host
Fiona is not just helping her find a
property she's also willing to stand as
a financial guarantor I think for all of
us we don't want to go on like this
forever but for us it's more what does
Kate want so my understanding is that
what Kate wants is as normal a family
life as she can have
and so
for her that means living independently
still in search of a place to call home
a few weeks later we go back to meet
anfisa of lasova and her mini Yorkshire
Terriers so that's our attend
and uh and this is you and one of the
whole people yeah
after spending a night in a church and
fisa says for a couple of days she then
slept rough in a summer tent in winter
in freezing conditions rejecting the
council's offer of a hotel because she
couldn't take her dogs I got a flu
because even we were applying to be
protected with blankets and duvets and
give warm to each other but it didn't
help me much because of the minus
temperature at night so I got flu
and fisa is now temporarily staying with
a friend of a friend but her experience
has even made her think twice about
leaving a war zone I just want to hide
you know under my blend kid just imagine
to close my eyes imagining I'm at home
on my bed in my flat and I'm just hiding
under the blanket at the place which is
I feel it's a like my own space since I
came here just I had a six months quite
peaceful life in my host family
I'm really very appreciated to those
people
but later on it's a nightmare